we have this this handy fusion reactor
in the sky called the Sun okay you don't
have to do anything it just works you
will whooping cold peace NPV hi welcome
to another cold Houston video to gogo
here a couple of weeks ago I talked
about Costa Rica running entirely off
renewable energy a feat that does build
some hope for our current climate
situation in the video I discussed how
Costa Rica managed to achieve this
through geothermal and hydroelectric
power but this setup isn't ideal for
every country on the planet so what
about a new approach a game-changing
method for clean energy for the entire
world
Elon Musk and his company Tesla plans to
provide the solution his company's home
battery technology is causing a lot of
hype after all for Tesla their electric
car was just the starting point to
change the way the world use it in
stores power think about the you know
the internet revolution that happened in
the 1990s this is another revolution
that's happening in energy so whereas in
the 90s we spread you know information
to the entire world now we're spreading
clean energy to the entire world a
couple of days ago in a press conference
filled with an atmosphere of excitement
reminiscent of a late 2000 Steve Jobs
keynote Elon Musk revealed a brand new
branch for his Tesla company Tesla
energy and its first product the power
warm what am I to talk about tonight is
about a fundamental transformation of
how the world works basically the power
wall is a polished plug-and-play battery
system that takes energy from the Sun or
the grid during the day stores it and
uses it during peak times in the evening
it costs between 3,000 and 3,500 dollars
and as the name suggests its small
enough to hang up on a wall it's
designed to look more like an art
feature rather than a piece of
technology that powers your home users
can stack up to nine of them together to
power as much as they need the batteries
are said to last 10 years with no
maintenance but does require a
professional to install elon states that
as company's technology will change the
world and I can somewhat agree with this
with solar efficiency getting up to 40%
and cost falling thanks to
manufacturing output cheaper green
energy could become a reality using the
United States as an example elan states
that with the aid of his battery
technology we would need solar panels
the size of the land area shown here to
rid the entire United States of fossil
fuels and most of that most that area is
going to be in rooftops so if you don't
need to disturb land you won't need to
find new new areas the obvious problem
with solar power today is that it's very
primitive in the sense that it's direct
usage and once the Sun Goes Away
it's game over this is where the tesla
powerwall wants to make its whole mark
on history the battery will smooth out
solar energy generation and store it for
peak time use at night where most of the
energy is used according to Elon it
would now be possible to completely go
off the grid
if you already have solar panels so
that's all very encouraging but there's
something missing what if you don't have
solar panels well as it turns out you
can still save money on energy costs you
can just simply store the energy from
the grid during the day when it's
cheaper and then use it at night when
the rate is lower it kind of makes sense
either way but as will soon see in this
video it's not actually the full story
so of course energy storage from solar
panels has been done before but not
really implemented properly usually it's
about three times more expensive doesn't
last nearly as long looks terrible and
does require some effort to get it up
and running
combined multiple systems there's not
one integrated place you could go and
buy a battery that just works here's one
way to think about it it's much the same
scenario as the electric car before
Tesla or the smartphone before the
iPhone with his capacitive multi-touch
screen and a capable OS that was scaled
down from the Mac Tesla also announced a
police scalable power pack that it plans
to sell to corporations to power
organizations on an industrial scale in
usual Tesla fashion all the patents for
this have been released for free to
encourage competition okay so what you
might be thinking I just want proof that
this actually works at all Wow the grid
it's actually zero
this entire night has been powered by
batteries of only that the batteries
were charged by the solar panels on the
roof of this building
so this entire night everything you're
experiencing is stored sunlight this
kind of sounds too good to be true well
a lot of people are thinking the same
thing and opinions are split all over
the internet forbs are stating taking
solar panels into effect that places
like Texas will have cheaper energy
costs holding on to the status quo as it
stands now whereas states where energy
is more expensive like California and
Hawaii we'll save money with the first
generation power wall but let's dig a
little bit further what nobody is
talking about is the power walls actual
output although a single power wall can
output 10 kilowatt hours it's only
capable of 2 kilowatts of continuous
power output if this sounds like
gibberish to you all you need to know is
that 2 kilowatts isn't really enough to
power the average household at peak
times for example you can't boil water
for your coffee in 1500 watt electric
kettle at the same time as making toast
in your 950 watt toaster so as it turns
out a fully off-the-grid home would
probably need to tesla powerwall and
that's not because it can't store
electricity efficiently but because of
its limited power output so that's the
point that a lot of other people have
been missing so realistically this kind
of technology will change the world but
not just yet so where will this
technology work best all the places that
will benefit the most are remote areas
of villages where power is limited or
unreliable areas where energy is
expensive and places with lots of
sunlight and an already established
solar panel user base places like
Australia where I live
so in conclusion although this
technology and this approach is
absolutely amazing this is just a first
generation product this is the very
worst it can be it's just a start think
about mobile phones for example back in
the 1980s they used to cost a fortune to
own and operate they were big and bulky
and heavy and they only lasted a few
hours and need a giant mast put around
the country to even function properly
the fledgling first generation of any
industry is a far cry from what it ends
up being at the endpoint it can be said
that the point of what Elon is doing is
to create an infrastructure that will
reduce
our alliance on the grid hoping solar
panels become more persuasive so we can
reduce our use of carbon fuels it's
about making our actual needs for energy
more sustainable and that's a good thing
so you future entrepreneurs out there
take note
anyway this has been - gogo thanks for
watching don't forget to leave a comment
give a thumbs up and subscribe if you're
new and I'll catch you again soon for
the next video
cheers guys it's me thinking